jackal virginie despentes
il est cependant évident à man le
morceau de corde coban illustrait le
titre de votre livre virginie qui
s'appelle teen spirit c'est votre
quatrième roman est voulue publié chez
grasset ça va voyager une bonne tête ça
ça va ouais ça va mais en bonne
compagnie vous avez un chapeau donc la
bonne surprise
virginie c'est que vous ne vous êtes pas
laissé prendre au piège de votre propre
image on est loin du trash et duarte
sexe de vos romans précédents c'est pas
baise-moi nombeuses moi je les ai déjà
fait mon avis je les réussis
ouais enfin c'est autre chose puis c'est
vrai que sur la tvh est de 20 par de
fret et les flancs parce qu'à mon avis
on m'attend au tournant
donc il fallait que je fasse un bouquin
ouais voilà on vous attendait pas il ya
un truc chez le narrateur cariste pas
éjaculer bon pas pour murs du tantrisme
un fabuleux way et puis j'arrive à des
gens très bien
et puis je m'écrase d'enculés la
gonzesse enfin bronzage ouais dit -
virginie vous êtes embourgeoisé ou non
j'ai l'impression d'avoir été récupéré
par le système
non non vu la sortie du film sarah la
première mention je suis tranquille ne
pas nous faire un bébé quand même non
non j'ai pas que ça à faire passer
optimiste non pas assez timide tu sais
pas c'est parce que j'ai tout ce qu'il
voudrait que la vie sur la terre va être
encore pire des années qui viennent
ouais t'as clara des trucs rigolos en
fait ils seront à travailler avant des
émeutes des trucs marrants quoi mais je
crois plutôt que ça va être
catastrophique
à la voir il ya des jours je me dis
vraiment cesseront futtaim group ans dès
maintenant la plupart du temps je me dis
plutôt un moment donné on va vraiment
avoir un régime totalitaire fort et ça
va être rigolo du tout pensé ça c'est ce
qui c'est ce que j'imagine mon lit du
mal à vous remettre à l'écriture
heureusement les mensualités que vous
verse les éditions grasset vous y ont
obligé c'est pas mal finalement
ouais sinon je me serais pas remise à
l'écriture après des trucs du film c'est
clair vallon c'est bien mais tu as on ne
serait pas payé je serais rien du tout
genre comme dans le gagner des sous quoi
faire alors j'ai attendu plus d'un an
avant de commencer j'ai pris des notes
l'effet des plans et puis après vous
l'avez fait en six jours le k way
pendant un an j'ai essayé de les créer
et j'y arrivais pas dire avec plaisir a
réagi à l'époque qu'un jour il fallait
vraiment le vendredi soir et le six
mètres
ouais moi je m'étais mise quand la main
puisqu'il tournait autour j'ai essayer
des trucs des histoires de l'histoire
des plans d'eau plans des débuts
d'autres des bus ag et se tournaient
autour qui vont au final après il
restait plus qu'une semaine donc là je
n'ai fait croire qu'il fallait le faire
je vais grasset qui téléphonait tous les
jours oh non non non pas croyait même
pas avec juillet prochain vous mettez
maintenu la pression
alors l'histoire c'est l'histoire de
bruno qui est un adolescent de 30 ans
qui est un écrivain raté à
or afobe la peur de la foule donc il est
bunkerisé chez lui ça fait deux ans
qu'il a pas mis le nez dehors et il vit
au crochet d'une certaine catherine bois
et puis un jour il a un coup de fil
d'une fille qui s'appelle alice qu'il
sautait à l'époque de sa jeunesse punk
elle est surtout bourgeoise 1 allée
subissons tous les donjons bourgeoise
fille de chirurgien
ouais ouais et lui fils de cheminot
voilà alors elle l'appelle ça fait 13
ans qu'il ne se sont pas revus elle veut
absolument le revoir il y va ils
prennent un café place de stalingrad et
elle lui apprend qu'il est papa d'une
fille de 13 ans et voilà ça lui tombe
dessus
c'est parce qu il arrive et alors c'est
pas fini parce que le soir et me rendent
chez lui et catherine la fille aux
crochets de laquelle il vit le virent
parce qu'elle en a marre de le voir
glander voilà voilà
et à partir de là donc il est dehors il
faut qu'il trouve chez qui aller
d'autres comprend qu'il rencontre la
petite ou qui la rencontre femme en a
tiré la rencontre moi c'est mon nom avec
un début un milieu et une fin des
plongées attention au sexe et oussalah
maintenant il ya l'histoire qui évite
aux biens alors au début avec cette
petite nalci donc il sa fille qu'à 13
ans qui ne connaissait pas au début les
patrouilles content que finalement il
dit à ses copains avec elle et puis
commence elle l'assumé
voilà oui même nom mondialement caraman
comme un serment une rencontre inespérée
compte pas très réaliste enfin sur
s'accélère puisque l'on peut faire des
trucs entre directement les unit donc
même s'ils passent de l'enfance et
l'adolescence et 8 passes de
l'adolescence à l'âge adulte
c'est un livre de ville mme passage
comme ça de génération en génération
il ya d'autres choses dans le bouquin il
ya c'est que ça reste assez crétin quand
même et comme ça ça a l'air pas trop
drôle mais en fait ça s'est très bien
passé d'histoire brut de décoffrage mais
il ya d'autres choses
et d'abord les compromis qu'il faut
faire dans la vie et la réussite sociale
et puis pas de pitié pour les autres
cider dans un monde
que vous jugez c'est un petit peu ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure de plus en
plus dur ouais il me semble qu'il ya de
plus en plus d'exclus excès plus en plus
difficile de contenir d'être dedans quoi
et que c'est plus en plus violent envers
ceux qui sont pas dedans encore à plein
plein de niveaux selon plein de critères
et que ça devient chiant que même sur
mance a rarement été aussi dur parce
qu'on est vraiment surveiller de partout
mais physiquement on est servi dans nos
têtes avec les psy on est surveillé
d'heures de travail d'une façon pas dans
tout comportement on est vachement
surveiller et c'est vrai que ça devient
vraiment pénible qu'on voit la maison il
ya de moins en moins des interstices
dans lesquelles ce qu'ils disent et les
plantes quoi aujourd'hui c'est difficile
de trouver des preuves unia n'a
carrément pas la mettre hors ces notes
une planque est à la fonction publique
ça existera bientôt plus
ces seize durci quand même le niveau 10
des gens est aussi fier la classe
moyenne blanche qui existaient qui
existait au moins en moins quoi quand
même qui est sacrifiée écrivain ce une
bonne blanca mais c'est pas une solution
collective
non là c'est qu'il faut écrire le temps
en temps c'est le problème c'est de ce
problème et francfort perd de livres
génial alors vous savez qu'une légende
de virginie despentes un kit et non pas
nancy mais nancy à l'âge de 17 ans elle
est partie vivre sur les pentes de la
croix-rousse à lyon
d'où votre pseudo d'ailleurs des pentes
où vivait à l'époque avec des rockers
alternative c'était quoi les béruriers
noirs c'est ça je veux parler mais
c'était un comprimé bien et alors
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'elle penserait
la virgin de l'époque c'est le vous
voyez moi je serais surprise pour le
coup de mou voire s'étire ardisson et de
la baronne ce serait plutôt plus
contente que de me voir
amis ses badges et de la chanson un reçu
vous êtes sorti non mais je m'en suis
pas sorti parce qu'est ce que j'y vis
pas donc les super rigolo tout le temps
pourquoi c'est chiant quand même s'est
lâchement effectivement de compromission
c'est vachement de rencontrer des gens
je m'en fous un peu de les rencontrer
c'est vachement de prise de tête que je
m'en fous d'avoir quelqu'un comme toi là
ah [ __ ]
voilà